Ngày hai một tháng sau công an thành phố Chíming cho biết quà đất cao điểm tổng giả xuất điểm bàn
lực lượng trức năng đã liên tiếp phát hiện sự lý nhiều nhóm người nước ngoài
hóa đậu chái phép, thú dữ số lượng lớn thiết bị định từ phục cuộc hua đậu trên không giảm mặt
giữ sự trí đạo của bàn giảm đốc công an thành phố
hai mì hai tổ công tác gió phòng của anh lý xuất dập cảnh chú gì
đã phố hợp kìm chá một gình sau chá mùa sáo cơ sở liệu chú
của anh đó phát hiện một chẳng sống mì cơ sở vì phạm quy định về khai báo tạm chú chung người nước ngoài
mà các bạn bá chăm mì một chân hợp vì phạm liên quan đến xuất nghiệp cạnh
lâu động trái phép, cứ chú trái phép và các hình vì khách
lắng chú ý lực lượng trức năng phát hiện nhiều địa điểm tập chung số lượng lớn cân dân nước ngoài
cũng hàng chá máy tính điểm thoại gí đau của thí bị mặt
khi quà điều chá nước đau cho thấy các lối tượng được tổ chức từ nước ngoài chỉ đạo sang Việt Nam推 điểm
lắm đặt thả tần ký thuật tuyển người và chuẩn bị vận hành các mùa hình người đạo chức tuyển
kêu quà nâng nhiều chá cơ mân thành vô chiming đã khởi tổ nhiều vụ an
mắt trảm giám các nước tượng đình quan để điều chá về hình vì tổ chức trong người khác
ở lại Việt Nam trái phép chá cơ mân thành vô các nước tượng đã cơ vãn hòn tất việc chuẩn bị cơ sở bất chất
và nhân sự những vị phát hiện gắn chạm chức phí chín khai hòn đau
kêu quà những đăng quyền cao các cơ sở liệu chú chá phành nghiêm quy định về khoản địa cứ chú
không tiếp t害 cho khai nguyên giúp cạnh, cứ chú trái phép, gốc phần bảo đam ăn điên cho tự trên đế bán